on this the fourth day of the fourth
month of the year of our lord 2022 the
washington post is finally admitting
that hunter biden peddled his father's
influence for big bucks all around the
world
now
many people have suspected the biden
family's cash for favors scheme for many
years now but we've had
irrefutable evidence of it since october
14 2020 when the new york post reported
on the contents of hunter biden's laptop
hard drive which revealed lots of
degenerate sex stuff and more damningly
lots of financial chicanery implicating
not just hunter but his big guy father
too
when that story broke two years ago the
entire liberal establishment conspired
to shut it down i had actually forgotten
until just now we posted a brief special
on it outlining what was in the laptop
what it really meant and we were called
conspiracy theorists and kooks and
cranks and crazy people turns out we
were 100 correct you know how much i
hate to say i told you so but you can
find it on my youtube channel
you were not allowed to post this sort
of this article at least to social media
you were accused of fake news if you
even talked about this thing you could
not privately message it and the papers
of record all denied it the washington
post's fact checker reported fact
checker quote unquote that he had quote
not been able to verify or authenticate
these emails
said that there were fears that the
emails could be part of a broader
disinformation campaign by russia
a slew of other washington post op-eds
called the hard drive contents
unverified said they had never been
authenticated and called the whole
report
sketchy
the rest of the establishment media did
exactly the same thing the new york
times and all the rest of them now
however the washington post is running
big headlines
inside hunter biden's multi-million
dollar deals with a chinese energy
company hunter it turns out made 4.8
million dollars
in retainer and consulting fees from a
dodgy chinese energy company in just 14
months because of his expertise in
chinese energy i don't think so i think
more more to do with his last name tony
babilinski who's a businessman who
worked with the bidens on their business
in china has gone on the record
admitting that 10 equity was being quote
held by h hunter for his father the big
guy
joe biden has been caught with his hand
in the cookie jar we are talking about
an historic degree
of corruption
and the most left-wing establishment
papers of all of them are admitting it
the question we should be asking
ourselves is why
why are these shameless propagandists
all of a sudden turning on the democrat
president
is it because suddenly they've given up
their decades of dishonesty they've
become honest newsmen overnight
or is it because biden's ratings are in
the gutter his presidency is a failure
and the establishment finally wants him
out before conservatives celebrate the
left's confession that they lied about
the laptop and rigged the presidential
election two years ago perhaps we ought
to focus on the present and ask
what are the swamp creatures up to now
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from raven queen
who says
being able to say a string of words
without really meaning anything is an
art form both biden and kamala have
mastered that's true there are two kinds
of politicians there are the conviction
politicians who really believe something
the things they can believe can be good
or bad doesn't matter they're the
conviction ones and then there are the
empty suit politicians like joe biden
like kamala harris
the conviction politicians i would
include obama in that
they
know what they want
so they're not just stringing
meaningless words together when they say
things that that seem kind of slippery
and oily they're doing it for a
rhetorical purpose they actually want to
get something done they want to do
something they empty suit politicians
they just want to be something they just
want to have a post office named after
them they just want to get fancy honors
at fancy parties and that's it and
sometimes the empty suit politicians are
the most dangerous of them all at least
when you're dealing with an ideologue
you know what they're after when it
comes to the blow in the wind
politicians they can be
the least predictable now when you want
to predictably protect your home i would
strongly recommend you check out ring
right now go to ring.com
knowles you know about rings video
doorbell it's amazing you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door
wherever you are in the world you know
perhaps about rings award-winning home
security system ring alarm
now you've got to go pro you've got to
go pro because when you've got the ring
alarm security system yes you're
protecting your physical home from
freeze from fire from flood from the bad
guys that's great but when you go pro
you're not just protecting your physical
home you're protecting your digital home
as well you're protecting your internet
usage you're protecting your debt you're
protecting
all of that and as we live more and more
of our lives online it's so much more
important to protect that cnet
absolutely loves these guys they call
the ring alarm pro a giant leap for home
security go check it out right now i am
so pleased to have teamed up with ring i
am so pleased to have gone pro to learn
more go to ring.com knowles kowles that
is ring.com
knowles
i hate to bring down the mood
i hate to
stop the celebrations for a second
because it's great i'm glad that the new
york post that not the new york post at
the washington post and the new york
times are admitting that the new york
post was correct in its reporting on
hunter biden's laptop i'm glad that
they're admitting the conservatives were
right two years ago
great i guess that's some validation
some affirmation doesn't mean a damn
thing now they already rigged the
presidential election by denying this
report
but okay great i'm glad that they're
admitting that we weren't just total
kooks and cranks
but please forgive me
if i'm a little skeptical that they've
changed their wicked ways and now
they're they're honest newsmen i don't
buy it for a second
conservatives are so guilty of this
we're so often fighting the last war
we're so often trying to relitigate the
past
we're so often so focused on on battles
that the left has already won that we're
not paying attention to what they're
doing right now it's like any con artist
in a shell game any guy posted up on a
street corner in new york city
you're you're following the hand that
they want you to follow you're not
seeing what that other hand is doing
over there in the corner why are they
turning on biden
why is it because they're honest i don't
think so i think it's because biden's
not that useful to them anymore and so
the knives are coming out and maybe
they're looking to get someone else in
there back when biden was the best bet
for the left to maintain power they all
went behind him and they rigged an
election for him and they censored
conservatives for telling the truth and
they changed the election rules and they
did everything they could they did
everything they could to give an
advantage to joe biden now that he's no
longer the one
i don't know maybe they're going to look
somewhere else maybe they're going to
look at kamala maybe they're going to
look at pete budage these things
generally speaking do not happen by
accident
and now it's not just the newspapers now
social media will let you post about the
hunter biden laptop now
some politics democrat politicians are
maybe willing to start talking about it
because biden is a failure they're
admitting that he's corrupt
and they already know that the guys is
the lights are on but nobody's home joe
biden was just giving a speech
discussing
his wife and discussing michelle obama
and talking about when one of them was
the vice president
and i'm deeply proud of the work she's
doing as first lady with joining forces
initiative she started with michelle
obama when she was vice president and
now carries on
and michelle is in
the who and the what and where am i now
it's unclear from biden's remarks if he
was calling jill biden excuse me
dr joe biden if he was calling dr joe
biden the vice president or if he was
calling
michelle obama the president or the vice
president either way of course neither
of them were the vice president or if he
was just getting confused because he was
the vice president and jill was the
second lady now she's the first lady
his pistons are not firing the way that
they're supposed to be he's slurring his
words he's dropping the definite
articles and i'm proud what she's done
joint commission on the he's just
not
with it
so he's reciting the talking points of
the radical left as best he can he on
transgender day of visibility joe biden
put out a scripted pre-recorded highly
produced video
where he was obviously reading off a
teleprompter they could have as many
takes as they wanted they could go into
the editing room do the best that they
possibly could and even then
it sounded like he was half asleep
to everyone celebrating transgender day
of visibility i want you to know that
your president sees you
jill come on doug our entire
administration sees you for who you are
made an image of god and deserving of
dignity respect and support
but we know it's hard
when there are those out there who don't
see you and don't respect you for
example the onslaught of
anti-transgender state laws attacking
you and your families is simply wrong
this administration is standing up for
you against all these hateful bills
and we're committed to advancing
transgender equality in the classroom on
the playing field at work in our
military in our housing and healthcare
systems everywhere simply everywhere to
parents of transgender children
affirming your child's identity one of
the most powerful things you can do to
keep them safe and healthy
any transgender american who's
struggling please know that you're not
alone
to parents and children alike please ask
for help
what's funny about his comments is that
if you
if you didn't know the context
if i didn't know the context i would say
i totally agree with what he said
he says that transgender children are
made in the image of god yes of course
that's true and affirming your child's
sex is one of the most important things
you can do to keep your child safe and
healthy that's true the problem is that
the words don't mean what joe biden is
pretending that they mean
when joe biden says affirm your child's
sex he's saying pretend that your boy is
a girl
he's actually saying you should deny
your child sex and and go along with
your child's delusion if your child is a
boy who thinks that he's a girl when he
says the children are made in the image
of god he's evoking a christian
understanding of sex well in the
beginning god created man both male and
female he created he them
so he he's
taking this christian understanding and
completely flipping it on its head and
you know that because of that middle
part where he says we need to put affirm
transgenderism we need transgenderism
everywhere not just in the corporations
not just in the government we need it in
the schools we need it in elementary
schools so he's he's gone all the way on
this i'm sure he didn't write a word
that he probably doesn't know what any
of it means he's slurring his words it's
it's doubtful that he's even more than
half awake while he's reading this but
he's articulating an extremely radical
view
of sex which is not popular the majority
of the vast majority of americans oppose
this stuff including the majority of
democrats oppose peddling transgenderism
in schools this is what i mean by the
dangers of the empty suit politician
he'll just do whatever he thinks will
benefit him he's obviously getting
pretty bad advice right now
and he's not all with it it does not
appear that he's the one calling the
shots some people believe this is
evidence that joe biden should be booted
from office using the 25th amendment
because he's just not all there i
actually think
the conclusion should be the opposite of
that i think it's an even darker
conclusion
about the state of our government one
thing we do know is joe biden needs to
go lie down and have a good nap a good
sleep and when you want a beautiful
beautiful bed to lie down on i would
strongly recommend thuma right now go to
thuma dot co
slash knowles your bedroom deserves a
refresh
your
room your home really matters a lot of
people don't think about it especially
guys but when you are in a place
either that place is going to slightly
elevate your spirits or it's going to
slightly lower your spirits okay and
you're probably not even going to be
conscious of it so help elevate your
spirits right now go check out the bed
by thuma handcrafted from eco-friendly
high-quality upcycled wood you will find
beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain they have a minimalist
design features japanese joinery
it will be super supportive for your
mattress it's breathable made to
naturally minimize noise and create
space it's made for how you live the bed
by thuma is backed with a lifetime
warranty ships right to your door in
three easy to maneuver boxes takes about
five ish minutes to assemble with no
tools required you can do it all by
yourself along with the bed suma offers
all sorts of other bedroom essentials
the nightstand the side table the tray
are perfect compliments create that
feeling of checking into your favorite
boutique hotel suite but at home with
the bed by thuma go to thuma dot co co
slash knowles and use code knowles to
receive a 25 credit toward your purchase
of the bed plus free shipping in the
continental us that's t-h-u-m-a dot c-o
slash knowles can wles enter knowles at
checkout for 25 dollar credit thuma dot
co slash knowles enter code knowles the
former white house physician to barack
obama ronnie jackson has come out and
said joe biden's got to resign his
cognitive decline is too much he says
quote biden is unable to articulate the
major foreign policy objectives of his
administration every time he tries the
white house swoops in to correct what he
said he has no idea what's going on his
cognitive decline is too much time to
resign
that's not my conclusion
it's sad to say
but
when i look at joe biden i don't think
wow this is evidence that our president
is so far gone that he has to resign
because it's so important who the
president is my conclusion is that it
doesn't really matter who the president
is because the government is kind of
running in the same crappy way that the
liberal establishment has been running
it every time they amass a sufficient
amount of power
and frankly even when there's a
republican president the liberal
establishment the deep state the
administrative state the executive
agencies the places where our our laws
are actually made and our government
actually works they still were basically
running the show and trump would throw a
wrench into the gears every so often but
they still had almost all of the power
so yes joe biden's head is made of
pudding at this point he doesn't know
which end is up he doesn't know what day
it is sure but it doesn't really matter
because it doesn't seem like he's the
one who's really running the government
i don't think he's writing the speeches
i don't think he's thinking about the
policies all that much and i don't think
that he's the one actually putting them
into effect and i'm not saying that
there's some small oligarchic cabal of
reptile monsters somewhere in a layer
underground that's really calling the
shots it's even more depressing than
that the way our government is run is
kind of just by this blob
it doesn't seem like anyone is really in
charge it's just this alphabet agency
does this and that alphabet agency does
that and then the corporations
push the propaganda lines of the
administration and the university is is
on board with that as well and the media
are pushing their line and it's all
working in concert but you can't quite
put your finger on it it's just the blob
it's just the liberal establishment it's
the scariest part of all because if if
joe biden were running the government
i'd say great impeach him and then we
can get rid of him and then we can do
something and we can take control then
we can win back the house in 2022 and
then we can win the presidency in 2024
but it's much harder than that how do
you how do you impeach disney how do you
impeach google how do you impeach
the
fda how do you you can't it's and it's
all how do you impeach yale it's just
all working in concert and that's the
real constitution right that's the real
lowercase c constitution that runs our
country yes would i like to get rid of
biden sure he's he is a bad president he
is the worst president of my lifetime
but that won't even come close to
solving the problem frankly it'll
probably make the problem worse because
we're going to get the one person in
america who's got a lower approval
rating than joe biden and that would be
kamala harris kamala harris
was just asked about the
biden
policy suggestion
that we need regime change in russia
remember biden went off script he said
we've got to kick putin out of power
and then the blob went into its effect
and said no he didn't really mean that
and then biden because he doesn't
believe a damn thing said no yeah you're
right i didn't really mean that
so so but he still called for regime
change in russia now kamala was asked
about this and her answer was
indecipherable
he said that vladimir putin um should no
longer be the leader of russia
do you agree
listen i think that you you
framed the point
quite accurately and well
which is america's policy has been and
will continue to be focused on the real
issue at hand which is one
the needs of the ukrainian people which
we will continue to support
through humanitarian assistance through
security assistance but also ensuring
that there's going to be serious
consequence for vladimir putin
and russian aggression as it relates to
ukraine which is why our policy from the
beginning has been about ensuring that
they're going to be real cost
exacted against russia in the form of
severe sanctions which we know are
having a real impact and an immediate
impact not to mention the the longer
term impact
which is about saying
there's going to be consequence and
accountability
did anyone listening
find an answer to the straightforward
yes or no question anywhere in that word
salad because i did not you know i try
to keep a bong under my desk to make it
easier to decipher what kamala harris
has to say i thought i could make it
without a hit of that haitian oregano
this time and i i could not but and i
doubt i could understand what she meant
even if i had ripped some of that
peruvian parsley
because it doesn't mean anything she was
just filibustering this is another
problem with with the
the
empty suit politicians
who just want to be something they don't
have a clear policy
she doesn't forget that she's got a flag
for joe biden she doesn't have a clear
policy view herself
and so she just fills up time it's like
when you're in school
and you're assigned a five-page paper
you got to write a five-page paper on
some topic
if you are really engaged in the class
you're going to think gosh it's it's
going to be hard not to write six or
seven pages because i know exactly what
i want to say how am i going to trim it
down so i can fit my thesis into just
five pages
and if you're just kind of going along
and you have to take the class and
you're not that interested in it but you
want to get a good grade and go to go i
don't know good college or good graduate
school then you think okay how am i
gonna how am i gonna fill up all those
words
on the
the can the conviction people think
how can i perfectly precisely say
exactly what i want to persuade people
and the empty suit politicians think how
do i fill up my word count well that's
kamala harris she's the she's like she's
like joe biden except somehow less
impressive that amazing at least joe
biden's lasted in washington a long time
kamala harris has been around for
exactly five minutes she's extremely
unpopular she has been able to work the
levers of power behind the scenes to
some degree
but i i do not want to impeach joe biden
i do not want to remove him with the
25th amendment i do not want that woman
in charge and frankly whoever is
technically running the show the liberal
blob is going to keep governing in the
same crappy way
kamala's answer here
not particularly
excellent there is an award for
excellence that is going around there
are all sorts of awards
for excellence in in our schools in
college high school
middle school and elementary school you
remember that but now the awards are
changing a little bit there's an award
at a minnesota middle school and this is
not the only school that's doing this
that offers an award for black
excellence
so i would not be eligible for this even
though i am somewhat swarthy i don't
think i quite make it far enough down
the line on the swatches to to count for
black excellence so you're excluding
most of the school if it's minnesota
you're definitely excluding most of the
school because it's a pretty white state
the
libs of tick tock posted this picture
and said this is extremely racist and
it's true i get why this award is
offensive to white people because you're
saying we're not you're not even
eligible for this award so that is
offensive in a way but it strikes me
that this award is much more offensive
to black people the award is for
positive school attendance
reading academic growth on the fast test
extracurricular participation really
basic stuff
and the premise of this award is that it
is unusual and noteworthy when black
students do something that is excellent
the premise of this award is hey good
job black student you've done the stuff
that we expect of every other student
that strikes me as pretty offensive much
more offensive to black people than it
would be toward white people
that but that is what the left is saying
you're seeing this argued everywhere not
just at the level of schools but at the
level of government and the law as well
rashida talib the george harrison of the
squad has just come out
and said that drug laws anti-drug laws
are an intentionally anti-black
political project
the war on drugs was designed as a
project to target our black and brown
communities
and the obvious racial disparities and
enforcement show us that it still is at
its core an effort targeting communities
of color through over policing
criminalization and mass incarceration
the more act will increase access to
federal benefits and establish a fund to
redirect resources into communities
harmed by the war on drugs
this is a good start on the road to
repairing the damage but we still have
work to do
we must be bold our goal must be to in
countries militarized quote jail first
ask questions later approach to
addiction
and to stop trying to solve social
problems with more criminalization
i strongly encourage my colleagues to
support the moore act this is a common
sense bill
on the one hand this is offensive to
white people because like a lot of these
racial identity politics
campaigns being pushed by the left
they're saying that non-white people
should get special treatment and
should be given particular consideration
and white people should not be given
special treatment or or given special
consideration
but on the other hand it seems much more
offensive to black people to say look
when we when we implemented anti-drug
laws that was clearly a a campaign
against black and brown people because
blacks can't help but do drugs what are
you going to tell black people not to do
illegal drugs it's impossible they need
them they love them they can't resist
they have no will of their own that's
what rasheeda saliva is saying strikes
me as much more offensive what has been
called the soft bigotry of low
expectations and it and it's so it's
harmful for everybody it's harmful for
white people to have laws that and a
political culture in which white people
are the only people that can be
disadvantaged or discriminated against
or insulted that is actually bad for
white people but it's bad for everybody
to so reduce the the expectations of
other racial groups in particular black
people to say of course you can't help
but do crack so we're going to let you
do that on the street we're going to let
you do crack on the street and do lots
of drugs and commit lots of crimes and
we're going to give and we're going to
give you the special wonderful
consideration to do that without getting
arrested because of the color of your
skin we're going to let you live and
squalor and destroy your life because of
the color of
your skin
it doesn't seem particularly generous or
charitable or
or just to me
we're living in a time of crazy
political chaos which is why you want to
put your assets in something tangible
that's why you got to check out birch
gold text nulls right now do not wait to
989898 when inflation is at seven
percent like it is now thanks to joe
biden's stupid economic policies that
paper money in your wallet is losing
value fast and
russia's full-on invasion of ukraine has
worsened the market's decline today an
ounce of gold is worth 1900 bucks it was
worth about 300 bucks an ounce in 2000.
i've been telling you for years that you
can buy gold from birch gold it is a
great hedge against inflation well did
you know there's another way to hedge
against inflation that is
silver silver and gold silver and gold
silver is also considered real money
historically speaking it's extremely
undervalued right now it's an industrial
metal that is in high demand for
everything from electric cars to solar
panels demand is only going to rise some
analysts think there is an unusual
dislocation in price that may present
real opportunities for silver to rally
over the next two years it's never going
to be worth zero right now you can buy
gold or silver put it into a tax
sheltered account if you want your free
info kit on how to do it text knowles
k-w-l-e-s to
989898 no obligation to get this info
text knowles to 98 98 98. you may have
heard
about the leaked disney lgbt agenda last
week you may have heard about it on this
show where we we talked about it a lot
well the god king of the daily wire
jeremy boring
announced a 100 million dollar
investment into dw kids we are putting
out kids content
because you can't take your kids to
disney parks anymore
you can't show your kids disney content
anymore because the disney executives
have said that they're going to push
radical transgenderism radical sexual
ideologies in their content
we've already hired the veggie tales
writers to help create our first two
children's shows chill a time about a
family of homeschooled chinchillas
doodles with noodles that centers on a
man and his puppet giving drawing
lessons and because in order to change
the culture you've got to make the
culture daily dailywire is making the
culture we need your help to do it
please go to dailywire.com subscribe use
code build the future for 45 off your
membership we'll be right back with a
lot more
there is some good news in the racial
politics front that is coming
specifically out of the courts
uh california a few years ago
put forward a corporate racial diversity
law this was signed by gavin newsom and
just back in 2020s only two years ago
it uh required that publicly traded
companies that were headquartered in
california have at least one member of
their executive boards from an
underrepresented community and the
under-represented communities include
african-americans latinos asians native
americans members of the lgbt community
on and on and on so the underrepresented
community that had to get special
treatment to be represented on the board
is just anyone but white people
that's that was the law
you on your boards just have add anyone
who isn't a white person
and this started with just one person
and then by the end of 2021
after 2021 then it had to be two people
and then it kept going up and it was a
gradual kind of law
a
judge in la county's superior court
just struck this down the case was
brought by judicial watch and that the
judge just struck it down the judge did
not explain the court's ruling but said
that the the rule
was illegal that you couldn't do this
sort of thing
that's good news if if corporations want
to add members of unrepresented
underrepresented groups to their boards
that's a fine thing and that has
happened naturally and that's fine if
they want to do it
but to rig the law
as has increasingly been done to create
a caste system based on race to make up
for some
[Music]
perceived wrong in the past either real
or imagined that is a very bad idea and
it will not make any of the racial
problems in america or any of our
broader political problems better it
will only make them worse that was good
news even better news coming out of a
court
in ohio
an appellate court just upheld a
decision to award gibson's bakery
millions and millions of dollars after
oberlin college smeared them as racist i
wrote about this story in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
hasn't gotten a ton of play but there
was a little bakery near the oberlin
campus
it's called gibson's bakery sold baked
goods and some other things you know
sold kind of little groceries and it
sold liquor
there was a group of black students who
went into the gibson's bakery
and
in their telling of the story
were followed around and discriminated
against and asked to leave because of
the color of their skin white supremacy
alive and well in ohio anti-black
discrimination
the school ran with this story
oberlin ran with the story encouraged
protests encouraged boycotts destroyed
this business
but the business did not discriminate
against these kids based on their race
the students were trying to steal liquor
that's what the business which
followed them around and then acute and
then kicked them out of the store for
trying to steal liquor the business was
totally right and the kids played the
race card
and accused the the bakery owners of
racism which is the worst thing you can
be accused of in modern america and then
the school using the huge weight of the
school
destroyed this business and the owners
of this business have since died they've
brought a lawsuit but they've since died
it ruined their lives it ruined their
livelihood and their business and now
this appeals court has upheld a 25
million verdict against oberlin good i
love it the only way that you are going
to change this hideous culture
of of racial grievance is to make the
elites pay
and it's not just making the government
pay and it's not just making the
politicians pay it's not even just
making the corporations pay it's making
the universities pay it's making the
press pay it's making the establishment
media pay it's all of those dispersed
decentralized power centers that allow
the left to run the entire country
they've all
got to pay ideally millions and millions
of dollars as we're seeing in this
verdict out of ohio really great
news they're not going to let up on
their own they're actually the liberal
establishment
is getting much more ambitious and much
more aggressive there's a nurse at a
school middle school
in uh connecticut
who was just suspended after she
revealed that one of her 11 year old
students was being put on puberty
blockers
against the parents
will
she said there was an 11 year old
student
on puberty blockers and that other
students
identified as non-binary so neither male
nor female without their parents being
informed this woman's name is kathleen
cadaford 77 years old was suspended from
the hartford public schools after
exposing this her exact words
as a public school nurse i have an 11
year old female student on puberty
blockers a dozen identifying as
non-binary all but two keeping this as a
secret from their parents with the help
of teachers social workers and the
school administration teachers and
social workers are spending
and a half hours a week influencing our
children not necessarily teaching our
children what you think is being taught
she went on to say children are
introduced to this confusion in
kindergarten by the school social worker
who teaches teaches quote unquote social
and emotional regulation and school
expectations
that's happening in the hartford public
schools are you a resident of hartford
are you a taxpayer in hartford or in
connecticut you should probably call up
your school board you should probably
call up your members of congress your
state representatives and your governor
and say that you don't want this crap in
their schools
if it's possible to bring suit if you're
a parent for instance in this district
and it's possible to bring a lawsuit
against the school district you most
certainly should you should probably
name specific administrators the
principal the superintendent you need to
hit them where it hurts which is the
purse which is the budget which is the
money which is their power
that's where you've got to hit them this
woman deserves an award kathleen
cadaford give her the michael noll show
award for
professional courage so often people
write into the show they say michael how
do i speak up at my office without
suffering any repercussions michael how
do i speak up in the classroom without
getting a worse grade
you can everything in this life has
costs and this woman is standing up for
what is right
in in an example of something that is so
clearly right preventing little kids
from being sexually mutilated by
perverts and idiots and radicals in
their elementary and middle schools
she's standing up for something that's
totally right and she's going to suffer
professional consequences she's already
been suspended she's probably going to
be fired doesn't matter she stood up for
what's right
i'm not saying you've got to go out
there and destroy your job you need to
be wise as a serpent and innocent as a
dove but we've got to push back
the vast majority of americans don't
think that 11 year olds should be trans
against their parents will okay the vast
major the majority of democrats don't
don't think that that should happen
but the sickos who who are in power
right now the the corrupt
stupid
people who are in the really subpar
people who are running the show right
now
all do believe that and and we still
have some political power in this
country and we've got to say no look at
what's happening in florida florida
passes a law they say you can't trans
the kindergarteners and everyone's up in
arms there's a there's a an article that
just came out on nbc news
it says i cannot teach in florida
lgbtq educators feel fear fallout from
new school law
following the enactment of what critics
call the don't say gay law some lgbtq
teachers have quit the profession
altogether
great
that sounds like is that a problem or is
that a solution that seems to me kind of
more like a solution because by the way
when they say lgbtq educators
they're not talking about the man who
maybe he has
divergent sexual desires or even
behavior but he just keeps it quiet he
doesn't bring it into the classroom he
doesn't have a rainbow flag in his
classroom he just
he keeps his private life actually out
of the classroom and he teaches kids
reading writing and arithmetic
or more likely you know musical theater
or something like that
they're not talking about those teachers
those teachers wouldn't be a problem
would they
no teachers who aren't indoctrinating
kids into weird sex stuff they're not
the problem the problem
for this law are the teachers who are
indoctrinating kids into weird sex stuff
of any kind those are the only teachers
who are going to have an issue with the
law and those are the teachers who are
running away from florida and that's a
great thing don't let the door hit you
on the way out bye-bye
bye-bye you can't teach in florida good
you shouldn't teach anywhere you should
have your licenses suspended if you're
in a place that requires a teaching
license you shouldn't be within 100
yards of children
good great stuff love that
problem solution
the left is really going into overdrive
on sexualizing the kids and they're
doing this i don't think they're doing
it just because they're pedos or
something like that you'll hear some
more excitable conservatives say well
it's just because they're all pedos i
don't think that's the case maybe some
of them are but i don't think that's
actually why i think the reason is they
realize that sex is an extremely
important drive in human nature they
know that education is about shaping the
entire person and they want to create a
whole generation of young of radicals
so they know if we can not only shape
the way kids think about history shape
the way kids think about literature but
shape the way that kids think and feel
and desire sex why then we've got them
that's what this is about and i'm not
just
you know imagining this out of the blue
this is a program that has been laid out
by prominent left-wing intellectuals for
more than 100 years you can read about
it in my book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is coming
out in pre-order by the way or in in
paperback rather in uh june number one
national bestseller
so that's what they're pushing they're
now pushing this not just in the
classrooms but in the movies that's what
the whole daily wire kids business is
about is in response to
not just disney but but corporations
like disney
which are pushing this stuff disney
pixar
has just announced
that they are going to re-insert
a same-sex kiss scene
in the buzz lightyear movie
be in response to the florida parental
rights and education law
they had made this movie
the buzz lightyear i guess it's toy
story 5. and
the they had included at some point a
gay kissing and they realized wait we
don't need a gay kissing in a movie
about toys for kids so they took it out
and then all of the
employees at disney threw a big fit
because the kindergarten teachers aren't
allowed to trans the kids anymore in
florida and disney didn't push back
enough and now they've reinserted the
scene
but i don't think it goes nearly far
enough unless we get an extended s m
sequence between mr potato head and the
slinky dog then pixar is simply not an
ally okay if you're gonna do it do it or
how dare you no lukewarm gay kisses we
need
whips and chains we need 50 shades of
of little bow peep in here okay
otherwise that's not nearly enough this
is sick this is sick stuff
that you would intentionally
fill up a kids movie
with radical
sexual agendas so now
my kid can't go see buzz lightyear
frankly not even because of one scene of
this or that but because we know that
there is this agenda
to radically restructure the way that
kids think about sex because the disney
executives admitted it on camera
that's that's on one level and then on
frankly even a deeper level you know
that the movie's not going to be as good
you know the movie is not going to be as
good as the original toy story for
instance or as lots of other movies the
reason woke movies are not as good as
old movies is because old movies are
dealing with
eternal questions of human nature really
i don't just mean any old movie i mean
classic movies movies that have stood
the test of time
are dealing with human nature
and woke movies are seeking to upend
human nature that's the woke radical
program
so
classical stories involve prince's
wooing princesses
and new woke stories involve you know
butch trans lesbian
princesses who hate princes who go out
and
fight ogres or something something that
has nothing to do with human nature okay
it's actually just a finger in the eye
of our traditional experience
of the world people are noticing that
we're pushing back on this how is daily
wire which is a big company was it 100
million dollar company or a little more
than that now
how are we going to push back against
companies that are worth hundreds of
billions of dollars well because those
companies that are worth hundreds of
billions of dollars are telling half of
america to pound sand
and the daily wire is willing to invest
enough money to make good high quality
content
and that that means that you've got
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
lots and lots and lots of companies it's
not just disney right it's disney it's
all the other five or six hollywood
studios it's all the other much smaller
independent studios it's all of the
tv networks and the netflix and the
amazon and all of it together is
splitting up now less than half of the
country
which supports this stuff and then daily
wires got this open runway
to provide just normal good content
that's not pedantic that's not didactic
it's just offering normal stuff to
people who don't want their kids to be
trans when they're four years old
that is a great opportunity and
conservatives need to seize it
and i'm so thrilled that the daily wires
seizing it and the left is noticing
for a long time the libs just ignored
what we were doing over here
not so much anymore
the daily wire has made it
we have made it because we were the butt
of a joke
on saturday night live on saturday
the conservative media organization the
daily wire said they'll spend a hundred
million dollars to create children's
programming to counter woke media
companies programs will include clifford
the big straight dog
and konto but in english
and one fish two fish that's how many
fish genders there are
the reason i say that daily wire has
made it after this joke on snl is not
because
we are seeking the approval of saturday
night live obviously we're not seeking
the approval of saturday night live and
we're not getting it they're making a
joke about us
but the jokes that they made about us
were not
they were not exactly mean-spirited
jokes they were jokes about the actual
controversy they were jokes about the
content and the people were laughing
one fish two fish that's how many fish
genders there are
the vast majority of people know that
there are only two genders
the joke is that
the in many ways that joke is a joke
about the woke companies that have gone
too far yes they're dinging us
but it's really about
frankly i think the deeper issue
especially on that final punch line is
that the vote companies have obviously
gone too far and there's a huge push
back against this from the majority of
americans there's a line that's wrongly
attributed to gandhi
but gandhi didn't didn't say it i think
it was actually a union worker who said
it back in the early 20th century yes it
is actually nicholas klein a trade union
activist said in 1918 first they ignore
you
then they ridicule you then they attack
you and want to burn you and then they
build monuments to you
and he said this
uh to the amalgamated clothing workers
of america convention you know you hear
politicians on both sides of the aisle
use it
for a long time the libs just ignored
what we conservatives were doing in the
culture
and
daily wire has definitely taken a
leading role in this but there are lots
there are other groups that have done
this as well
and and the libs ignored it
now we've moved on to the next stage
which is
they're mocking it they're mocking it
because they can't ignore it anymore
and they can't ignore it anymore because
the blob those liberal institutions of
power that govern us from hollywood from
the classrooms from all over the place
from big tech
they have lost the common sense
i mentioned this also in my book
speechless
one of the really genius
intellectual
figures on the left a man named antonio
gramsci said the reason that left wing
specifically marxist revolutions weren't
working
is because
you in order for a revolution to work
you need to have the common sense
the reason the communist revolutions
didn't work very well in the 19th
century is because the proletariat
didn't want to be freed from their
chains the workers of the world didn't
want to come together and unite and
overthrow all of their traditions they
actually liked their traditions they
liked their customs they liked all those
things much more than they liked the
kooky theories of the left
and so gramsci said no you've got to get
into the culture you've got to conquer
the culture you've got to grab a hold of
the common sense which they did for a
while and and the left did a pretty good
job of making conservatives seem super
duper fringy
no more
no more the
florida is the perfect example of this
terry mcauliffe running in virginia is
the perfect example of this
he tried a lot terry mcauliffe in
virginia or not terry mcauliffe glenn
younkin rather who beat terry mcauliffe
glenn younkin
tried a lot of different themes for his
campaign we're going to cut taxes we're
going to deregulate none of that was
working then he said hey we're not going
to trans your kids in school boom he
wins even in a blue state
ron desantis the libs have tried
everything to make that guy seem like a
radical to make him seem like a fringe
figure they they
just expressly lied about the law in
florida they called it the don't say gay
bill they pushed that through all of
their media organs still didn't work the
majority of americans still support
the bill
it's
the way to understand transgenderism i
made this argument during my speech at
washburn which if you missed it it was
really wonderful to be at washburn
university we had a capacity room they
actually added 50 more chairs to the
room just to try to squeeze people in
but there were 200 people who were
turned away at the door was a really
really great event
the thesis of my speech was that
transgenderism needs to be rejected
entirely and that it doesn't make any
sense on the biological level on the
psychological level and on the
theological level that transgenderism is
actually a religious movement that draws
on themes of gnostic dualism and i
laid out my argument for that and the
libs will tell you you're crazy you're
insane it's not a religious movement at
all transgenderism it's it's not
religious it's purely biological and
then they post videos like this
hi everyone
i just wanted to get on here to say
happy visibility day to my trans queer
and non-binary family
i feel so honored to be able to
celebrate this day
my name is lavender lou
um in my mid-20s i am currently
you know posted up in some stolen
multnomah lands um i identify as two
spirit and have my relationship with my
divine masculine and my divine feminine
are very omnipresent every single day i
have very much an embodiment of male and
female energy that
doesn't sway
to all my other trans family i want you
to know that i see you
that i love you
that this universe is undergoing an
immense reconstruction right now but
that we've got this
so take that christians take that you
bible thumpers get your religion out of
my scientific transgenderism movement in
which i am a two-spirit with my divine
masculine and my divine feminine energy
because the energy man the energy's
moving in the universe this is the
dawning of the age of aquarius because
of that science right you saw that did
you see the two spirits under the
microscope
did you did you see the divine
masculine through the telescope in the
no probably you didn't
it's obviously a religious movement
this is where conservatives go a little
wrong too because we'll some we use this
phrase biological mail i get we
practically people do it because if we
don't bend the knee in any way to
transgenderism the libs can just
completely kick us out of the public
square shut down for all intense
purposes shut down conservative outlets
kick us off of social media tactically i
get why sometimes people use it but it's
dumb it's it's not going to work it
concedes the premise of transgenderism
that you can be biologically male but
psychologically female or something like
that and moreover when we try to argue
against transgenderism from the
perspective of science we completely
lose the argument because it is not in
any way a scientific movement it's a
movement about the relationship of the
soul to the body about two spirits and
divine masculine and you know what i'm
talking about man
so good apply the rigor of theology to
it theology is faith-seeking
understanding theology isn't some
made-up fantastical nonsense quite the
opposite actually theology takes made-up
fantastical nonsense and applies logic
and applies rigor to it and says okay if
we're thinking just as in science
you there are lots of superstitions in
science and then you apply rigorous
examination to discard the superstitions
about the physical world and figure out
what's really going on so too that's
what theology does to the metaphysical
world and if you don't if you're not
willing to use that express kind of
language then you're going to end up in
the gobbledy group of two spirits and
divine masculine and and the energy man
you're gonna end up sounding like joe
biden and nobody wants to do that i'm
michael knowles this the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire